(upbeat soothing music)
- The vision of Tencent
is to connect people
and connect everything.
We build our product by industry
which means we have Smart game cloud,
like Smarty cameras,
Smart internet.
A lot of enterprise customers come to us,
and they wanna get help from Tencent,
and Tencent cloud.
You know all over the world
people will ask for IBM consulting,
IBM cloud,
and now, I think maybe IBM can bring us
to this enterprise world,
so we can work together
to change this kind of enterprise view.
So that means they will
put a lot of effort
and research and determine
the clouds strategy,
how to serve their customers,
how to help their
customers to grow on cloud.
If we put our product onto IBM cloud
for the customers,
they have the same experience,
and they can extend it
to any other regions
that are IBM cloud has.
I believe that
if we can now say
that we work with IBM at enterprise level,
the companies will be convinced
that we can deliver a more
comprehensive solutions
for them together with IBM
because now, you know,
cloud change everything.
Especially, now,
I think we'll be most of the gaming,
internet,
mobile apps are cloud based.
And the last and important
part is enterprise.
How we can using Tencent
knowledge about the internet
together with IBM's
knowledge about enterprise.
Combine them together,
they'll be the new revolution.
(upbeat soothing music)